[Music]
scott is with us scott is in nashville
hi scott welcome to the ramsey show
hey there dave how you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
um yeah so i recently moved down to
nashville right um and i'm starting to
look at purchasing my first house
um
and being that i've never been a
salaried employee before and this is all
kind of brand new to me
i'm trying to figure out how to
prioritize my money in order to
uh most efficiently go about purchasing
my house
um
and
so right now
how old are you
i'm 23. good what do you what do you
make
uh so i made 43 000 a year um and then
after deductions and taxes and
everything come out it's more like 25
000 take home okay
cool
now uh i want to ask you this scott do
you have any debt right now
uh i got about 7 000 left um that's all
on a car note i just paid off my student
loans today good for you awesome way to
go man congratulations yeah well here's
the deal
i love that that you're moving here and
you want to buy a house but i want you
to get rid of this debt first do you
have an emergency fund do you have any
savings right now
uh i got about 5k for the way
you have 5k saved
yeah okay so here's what we're going to
do if you're following our plan and not
scott's plan here's what i want you to
do you're going to take 4 000 of that
and pay the car down today which is
going to take you down to a thousand
right
and then we're going to get aggressive
on that remaining 3k and with your
income you should be able to crush that
within a few months and then i want you
to save up a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
so once you know what expenses you're
gonna have living here fill that up and
then we can talk about saving up for
this house and that's where baby step
three b comes in where we save up
aggressively for that down payment for
about two years and uh you know in that
two years you might be in good luck
because uh the market may slow down here
in nashville things are crazy right now
dave yeah so scott um
this this whole thing is new to you and
this idea of getting on a plan and
working through george just outlined for
you what we call the baby steps and it's
the baby steps the shortest distance
between where you are today and becoming
wealthy
and if you do things in a very precise
proven order you'll bring less pain to
yourself and more probability
to going into wealth and so that's what
he just outlined for you but also
involved in that is just learning how to
handle money overall and that's a brand
new subject i mean you're a young guy
just getting started first time out
first job in a new city so here's what i
want you to do
our class is financial peace university
on how to handle money
included in that is every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
the whole thing is on sale right now for
99
uh for a one-year subscription to ramsey
plus which puts you in this okay
what i'm going to do is i want to give
it to you free
okay wow thank you
however
if i do that there's two conditions
number one you have to promise me you'll
actually freaking do this stuff
yeah of course you have to actually look
at it and do it if i give it to you and
just waste it that's a bad thing the
second thing is when you're rich someday
and you will be if you follow these
steps i want you to find a 23 year old
guy who's just getting started and i
want you to buy it for him
someday okay okay but that's that's
later it's only if everything i teach
you works okay and um you know you don't
have to pay it forward if there's
nothing to pay from yeah so i was in
scott's place i was 23 moved here
started working here
and i'm rooting for him i see myself oh
and by the way you're how old 32 now and
your house will be paid off when in a
few months
just like that you got this buddy just
like that hold on kelly will pick up
scott she'll get you signed up for a one
year on ramsey plus and put you into
financial peace university make it
happen brother